[Musique]
l'exclusivité de présentation pour le
groupe crucial numa ou dolma Dante Sugar Hill
Gang
Hesh un nouveau polygone de machine assis ici
top le hibbott le hippie-dippie hip
hip hoppy n'arrête pas la raquette est le
bébé bébé cookie asseyez-vous sautez le boogie
à  le rythme du boogie DB maintenant ce que
vous entendez n'est pas un test Je rappe
en rythme et moi le groove et les
amis vont essayer de bouger vos pieds voyez je suis
un micro et je voudrais dire bonjour à
le noir à droite le rouge et le
marron du jaune violet mais d'abord j'ai
eu un bang bang
tu n'arrêtes pas de bercer la rivière qui fait
bercer ton corps Gosei pourquoi tu as entendu ma
voix de ce que j'ai amené deux
amis et  le suivant sur le micro est mieux
connu comme la dame qui montre le plus de bonnes
choses c'est drôle j'adore ça je
suis chez vous maintenant mesdames venez et mesdames
bonnes juste pour vérifier mon émission de disco et
me vérifier c'est ce qu'ils font le
rythme de signature est  tellement nouveau je suis le
scientifique Big Thicket formidable le
maître
le commun  erreur du match 2g mais
les phénomènes au rythme sur dans notre je
disais jamais rappeur avec j'ai fait
du rap rapper en rythme j'aime ça
comme ça
le rap
toi
[Musique]